welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition aka the guy who's
living in his own loop right now and
this episode were breaking down one of
the craziest fan theories on Westworld
that is that caleb is actually sir axe
brother it's a theory that made me
chuckle when I first heard it I was
laughing then crying then laughing some
more then at about 3:00 in the morning I
still hadn't stopped thinking about it
and after researching the topic I think
there's a lot of evidence to support it
throughout this video we're going to be
going through the ins and outs on the
theory and discussing why it may be true
there will be heavy spoilers here so if
you want fully co-op with the show then
I highly recommend that you turn off now
make sure you subscribe to the channel
for videos on Westworld every week and
if you enjoy it then please hit the
thumbs up button without the way thank
you for clicking this now let's get into
a breakdown of whether caleb is sir axe
brother or not okay so this theory was
dropped on my breakdown of episode 5
yesterday by trend Fung Petra I hope I
pronounced that right
though it was pretty short and sweet it
did start nipping away at my brain and I
haven't been able to stop thinking about
it since it's made me really question
everything that we know about Caleb and
everything that we don't the guy is a
real mystery when you lay it all out and
on the surface he's a bit of an enigma
so let's start by talking about
everything that we do know about him
firstly caleb is a war veteran that was
shot in the head during his service his
best friend Francis died right in front
of him and since then he's lived a
blue-collar lifestyle and able to
progress beyond it because of what
Rehoboam has predicted for him in order
to make money on the side and pay for
his mother's medical treatment caleb
occasionally takes part in criminal
activities these are assigned to him
through an uber like Act known as Rico
Caleb was abandoned as a child by his
mother and he was left at a diner he
vividly remembers a waitress named
sorrow that gave him a cheeseburger and
strawberry milkshake to help calm his
nerves due to the anxiety caused by his
mother disappearing he vomited it back
up and eventually he wound up in social
services these memories of very vivid
for Caleb and may in fact showcase
they are plants which we'll discuss in
just a bit Caleb's mother was found six
months later and she was diagnosed with
schizophrenia his mother no longer
recognizes him and before meeting
Dolores he lived in pretty much his own
loop with no friends prospects or really
anything beyond his job
I miss you George now where things get
interesting is because in Episode five
Liam Dempsey junior looked at the
character through his AI lace glasses
and he seemed shocked at what he saw he
did not divulge this information but he
did clear up that he wasn't the one who
sent Caleb and Francis off to war he
said throughout the entry that Caleb did
not really know who he was and no it
could have been the character trying to
mess with him it does seem unlikely and
his dying breaths
Dempsey jr. said you did it and no we
don't have any clarification on this the
flashbacks that Caleb got did tease a
couple of things now I think even
without the theories we can take that
Caleb at some point has had his memory
wiped
someone with clear access to his past
such as Dempsey junior could see that
the character didn't really have one and
therefore we can take a lot of his
memories as being fabrications in the
finale of episode five we also got a
flash of Caleb in a reeducation Center
which we learned through our episode
five or we're outliers and anomalies are
sent in order to stop the world from
descending into chaos these are flagged
up by Rehoboam as being impossible to
predict and therefore they are removed
from civilization sir acts brother was
amongst them because apparently he
planned to kill Dempsey senior at the
end of the episode we learn that serac
did in fact kill Dempsey senior anyway
so taking his brother out of the
equation in hindsight did seem a bit
fruitless serac similar to his brothers
on me is also very difficult to predict
and it seems wrong of the character to
send him to a re-education Center for
wishing to carry out the same crime that
he eventually would now though we don't
know what goes on in these facilities
there are certain things that we can
guess when we are given a glimpse into
their inner workings we can see that
those sent there are not killed rather
they are looked after and watched over
by doctors the only reason I think that
they will be kept like this is because
they are pumped back into the system at
some point the fact that they are also
called reeducation centers
give us a big clue as to what really
goes on there it is possible that the
re-education is a sort of brainwashing
technique that takes away their identity
and then gives them a new one complete
with new memories in the brief flash
that we see of Caleb in the center a
doctor is standing over him and he's
wearing goggles throughout the season we
have learned that these goggles can
provide highly advanced VR imagery and
if one was subjected to it long enough
it is possible that they would believe
this to be their reality I believe that
this is confirmed by serac who states
that he is merely changing those held
captive there whilst this is likely a
psychological change due to technology
in the world it would also probably have
to be a surgical one-two in Westworld
everyone's face and data is somewhere in
the system and in order to avoid them
flagging up anywhere or perhaps
regaining their memories through looking
at the wrong faces serac would likely
have to change the way that they look
now whether caleb is surak's brother or
not we don't know for definite but we do
know that caleb was indeed processed at
such a facility this could explain why
Caleb's mother does not recognize him
but if this theory is correct then it
could go beyond that now if you were
going to give someone a new identity
does it not make sense that instead of
just making one up you instead take it
from someone who already existed say
perhaps a dead soldier now again we do
know that caleb was shot in the past but
what if this was the real Caleb and he
died from the wound or the Caleb that we
saw at the pier killing himself what if
that really happened what if that was
the real Caleb and instead of completely
starting from scratch serac removed the
death from the system and made his
brother look like Caleb and placed him
back into it with the face and memories
of this dead soldier we know that serac
has a lot of control over data as he was
able to remove himself so it does make
sense that he could also remove deaths
from records as Caleb's friend Francis
had already died it would be possible to
have an AI system like the one we see
Caleb using as a way to reinforce the
notion that Caleb thinks he is who he
thinks he is also Caleb's mother is the
perfect person to align the character
with she clearly does not recognize her
son however all questions of why this
could be the case
to decide because of a mental illness
say you had to give someone a new
identity will you not make the most
sense to take someone whose best friend
had died and whose mother had a mental
illness that meant no one would believe
her questioning why the man that came to
visit her wasn't his son makes a lot of
sense and though caleb could have just
been a random person that also just so
happened to be an outlier Dempsey's
words sick with me alot he clearly says
you did it and his dying breath and this
could mean that he was actually the one
that bailed Rehoboam he could be the
person that created the machine that
imprisoned everyone there's also an
interesting scene in the hangar when
Dolores talks to serac when caleb
appears there's a possibility that
Surratt could see him
however Dolores begins to walk shifting
him in order to stop him from looking
over she eventually stops just before
caleb comes into surak's eyeline and
then ends the conversation by taunting
him about his brother is it possible
that this was a direct nod to Caleb and
that she was hiding her ace in the hole
so that Surratt could not see him I
think so yeah we do know that Dolores
and Caleb are heading to a re-education
Center to seemingly gets Eric's brother
but could they actually be going to book
Caleb into a machine that will bring
back his memories thus getting Jean me
it is possible and even if it turns out
to be untrue it's definitely one of the
funnest theories I've seen so far on the
show
so in summary on me was taken out of the
equation by serac and then brainwashed
into going back into the system he was
given the identity of a man who had
either committed suicide or died during
combat and this notion was reinforced by
an AI system used to mimic the soldiers
friend the vivid memory implants he
received similar the hosts were laced
with tragedy and these grounded him and
tied him to his narrative this is
something that we've seen works in
Westworld
jean me was told that a woman in
hospital was his mother and as she
suffered from schizophrenia any
questioning of why his son was different
was brushed to the side her medical
bills needed to be paid and as Caleb
believed that she was his mother he
wouldn't stray too far and would remain
in a system in order to care for her we
know that jianmi didn't have a maternal
figure and he was pretty much raised by
his brother
so being tied to this figure does
love sense however deep down he knew
that his friend's mother and life didn't
really feel real and this is why when
Dolores arrived she did he is slowly
beginning to remember everything and
eventually he will discover the truth
upon returning to the re-education
Center he will awaken similar to the
hosts and show that they are not too
different in this world which will unite
them together and bring insight down oh
it was just some random guy Dolores
happened to bump into now obviously I'd
love to hear your thoughts on the theory
and if you agree with it or not
comment below and let me know and if you
enjoy this video then please drop a
thumbs up as we massively appreciate it
and make sure you check out our
breakdown of episode 5 which is gonna be
linked after this you want to support
the channel from as little as 99 cents a
month then please click the join button
below
we massively appreciate you and as a
thank you you get access to content
early you can come chat to us after the
show either follow us at definition
whitey or click the discord link in the
description below those are the best
ways to keep up to date with heavy
spoilers so hopefully we see over there
very soon this is the channel for people
who are never missing television so if
that's the kind of thing you like you
need to subscribe to definition thanks
again for taking the time to watch this
you've been the best and I'll see you
next time take care peace
[Music]
you
[Music]